This is the beginning of Volume 6, November 1, 1903. When the soul does all her actions
for the soul purpose of loving Jesus, she walks always in the daylight. It is never
nighttime for her. So walking in the daylight is John 8, 12, and John 9, 3. Jesus said,
"If you follow me, you will be walking in the daylight." So Louisa says, "Continue
in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself, and I saw myself as a little steamboat.
I was all surprised at seeing myself reduced to that shape. In the meantime, my adorable
Jesus came and told me, "My daughter, the life of man is a steamboat. Here Jesus is
using images of everyday life that are all around us." He will talk about electricity
when they put electricity together, for example. And just as it is fire alone that allows the
steamboat to move and the more lively and the bigger the fire the faster it runs, while
if the fire is small it moves at a slow pace, and if the fire is extinguished it remains
motionless, it's the same for the soul. If the fire of the love of God is big, it can
be said that she flies above all things of the earth, and she always runs and flies
towards her center, which is God. Now I want to give you God is love, 1 John 4 7. Our God
is a consuming fire is Hebrews 12 29, and Deuteronomy 32 11 to 13 that we're walking
with the Lord guiding us. If then the fire is small in her soul, it can be said that
she walks with difficulty crawling and getting all muddy with everything of the earth. If
then the fire is extinguished, she remains motionless without the life of God within
herself. As though dead to all that is divine, that is the issue that the Lord is dealing
with. You can be alive to the earth, but you can be dead to the things of God. And it's
the alive to the things of God that are the important things. So then he said, "My daughter,
when the soul does all of her actions, for the soul purpose of loving me," now in all
of these writings, that's the only motivation that Jesus accepts, that we will do everything
for love of him. And she wants no other recompense for her work, but my love alone, then she
walks always in the daylight, because selfishness and self-interest are not going to be destroying
things. It's never a night time for her. Even more, she walks within the sun itself. Now
in these writings, the sun is a symbol of the divine will. So she walks within the Lord
or within God herself, which almost like steam surrounds her to let her walk within
herself, making her enjoy all the fullness of light. Not only this, but her very actions
serve as light for her journey. Matthew 5, 17, Jesus tells us that we have to be light
for the world. And so it increases for her new light all the time. Whenever we're relating
to the Lord, he gives us new things all the time. So November the 8th, 1903, Jesus tells
how the love of neighbor must be. Now the whole law and the prophets Jesus tells us in
Matthew 22 hangs on love of God and love of neighbor. The whole 36 volumes of Louisa
hangs on love of God and living in the divine will. So November the 8th, Louisa says, as
I was in my usual state, I was praying for certain needs of other people. And blessed
Jesus, moving in my interior told me, for what purpose are you praying for these people?
In other words, why are you doing it? And Louisa said, Lord, and you, for what purpose
did you love us? He said, I love you because you are my own thing. And when an object is
one's own, one feels compelled to love it. It is like a necessity. So Louisa said, Lord,
I am praying for these people because they are your own thing. Otherwise I would not
have interested myself. And he placing his hand on my forehead, almost pressing it said,
ah, it's because they are my own thing. This is how the love of neighbor should be all
the time. That's Matthew 22 verses 37 to 40. That the love of neighbor, that we love them
because they are God's. Now, as we go on, Louisa is going to say, but they are your
images, Lord, in order to press home her point that she is loving and interceding for people
who are not only belonging to the Lord, but they are in his own image. So November the
10th, 1903, how true love forgets himself. Continuing in my usual state, Louisa said,
I saw blessed Jesus for just a little saying to me, my daughter, true love forgets himself
and lives out of the interests, the pains, and everything that belongs to the beloved.
So that's Matthew 1624. If you truly love, you will live for the beloved. It's that
simple. Someone who lives for themselves doesn't love. So Louisa said, Lord, how can one forget
oneself when we feel ourselves so much? It's not something far away from us, you know,
or separated, which can easily be forgotten. And again, Jesus added that that is precisely
the sacrifice of true love, that while one has oneself, he must live out of everything
that belongs to the beloved. So even though we're aware of our weaknesses and our sinfulness
and all the rest of it, we don't stay there. We actually live out of the love of God. Even
more. If he remembers himself, this memory must serve him to become more industrious about
how to consume himself for the beloved object. So that means if the Lord loves somebody as
weak and poor and miserable as me, then he deserves to be really served by someone who
doesn't deserve to be his servant. And if the beloved sees that the soul gives all of
herself to him, that's Deuteronomy six, chapter six, verses four to 10, that you would love
the Lord with all your heart, with all your soul, with all your mind, and with all your
being, note the all, not some of yourself, but all of yourself. So if the beloved sees
that the soul gives all of herself to him, he will know well how to repay her by giving
her all of himself. That's what the exchange is, this marvelous exchange that goes on between
God and us, we give him everything he gives us everything. We get the better deal. He doesn't
get much. So he he he repays by giving the soul all of himself and letting her live out
of his divine life. That's a wonderful deal for us. So one who forgets himself completely
finds everything. If you don't forget yourself completely, you're not in a position to find
everything because you're occupied with the stuff you've held on to. Moreover, it is necessary
to see the difference that exists between what one forgets and what one finds. If you find
a diamond ring, you wouldn't mind throwing away something that was worthless. One forgets
what is ugly and finds what is beautiful. One forgets nature and finds grace. One forgets
passions and weaknesses understood and finds virtues and strengths understood. One forgets
poverty and finds richness. One forgets foolishness and finds wisdom. One forgets the world and
finds heaven. Now that whole section there should really be colored and underlined. It's
one of the great gems of these writings. So November the 16th 1903. There's no sacrifice
without denying oneself and sacrifice and denying oneself to rise to the most pure and
perfect love. So you can't have any sacrifice without denying yourself and you need both
sacrifice and denying yourself if you're to rise to the great love that the Lord is
calling us to. So Louisa says, "This morning as I was outside of myself, I found myself
with baby Jesus in my arms and with a virgin who laid me on the ground to make me suffer
the crucifixion, not with nails but with fire, placing a charcoal fire on my hands and feet.
Blessed Jesus was there assisting me while I was suffering and he said, "My daughter,
there is no sacrifice without denying oneself." That's Matthew 1624. And Jesus says that this
denial of oneself is for everybody, whether you're in the divine will or not. In other
words, if you're living an ordinary spiritual life, the church has told us that this denial
of self is absolutely essential. And if we don't deny ourselves, then divine love cannot
be born in us. So there's no sacrifice without denying oneself. And sacrifice and denying
oneself give rise to the most pure and perfect love that mark chapter 9 verse 49.
And since sacrifice is sacred, it happens that it consecrates the soul to me as a sanctuary
worthy of me to make of it my perpetual dwelling, 1 Corinthians 3 16. No, you're not that you
are the temple of the living God and that God dwells in you. So let's sacrifice work
in you and render your soul and body sacred so that everything may be sacred in you and
consecrate everything to me. Now, this is all preparation for living in the divine will.
We have to put aside the old self. We've got to put aside the demands of human nature.
We've got to put aside our will in order that the divine will and the divine love will
take over. If we don't do our part, there's nothing for the Lord to work with. So November
the 19th 1903, while one is nothing, one can be all.
Louisa says continuing in my usual state, I saw blessed Jesus in my interior and a light
in my intellect. That means infused knowledge. She was given infused knowledge. So this light
said, while one is nothing, one can be all. In other words, as ourselves, we are nothing.
And in these writings, we have to acknowledge our nothingness and simply throw our nothingness
into his allness so that he's completely free to work with us. But how? One becomes
all through suffering, he says. Suffering makes the soul become pontiff, priest, king,
prince, minister, judge, advocate, repairer, protector, and defender. That's some list.
Notice that suffering has this extraordinary fruit in us. And since true suffering is the
suffering wanted by God in the soul, not suffering that we bring on ourselves as a result of
our sins, but suffering that the Lord has given to us. If the soul appeases or calms
herself, that means she becomes reconciled to the divine will. And if she surrenders
herself completely in God's will or God's holy volition, this appeasement or calming
or surrender united to suffering allows the soul to rule over justice, to rule over the
mercy of God, to rule over men and over all things. And that's called reigning with Christ.
And that's Romans 5 17 that the Lord said that we could reign with him. Now, just as
suffering gave Christ all the most beautiful qualities and all the honors and offices
that the human nature can contain, in the same way by participating in the suffering
of Christ, the soul participates in his qualities and in the honors and offices of Christ who
is all. As the chart tells us, we will receive everything through him with him and in him.
So I'll give you Philippians 4, 13, I can do all things in Christ. So we now come to
November the 23rd, 1903. There is no beauty that equals suffering for God alone. Now,
it doesn't say suffering, it says suffering for God alone. Louisa says, I felt impressed
in my interior by what I had written above, as if it were not according to the truth.
As soon as I saw blessed Jesus, I said, Lord, what I have written is not right. How can we
have all of this through mere suffering? And Jesus said, my daughter, don't be surprised.
Indeed, there is no beauty that equals suffering for the love of God alone. Notice he says,
there's no beauty. We don't want to associate the word beauty with suffering at all. Two
arrows come out of me continuously, one from the heart, which is love, and wounds all those
who are on my lap. That means touches or penetrates. That is those who are in my grace. This arrow
wounds, mortifies, heals, afflicts, attracts, reveals, consoles, and continues my passion
and redemption in those who are on my lap. That means those in relationship with God.
That this loving arrow of love that comes out from him has all of these different effects
in us according to what is actually needed. Sometimes it mortifies us because we need
to grow in humility or self-knowledge. Sometimes it heals us because that's the need. Sometimes
it afflicts us because we need to maybe look at our consciences. Sometimes it attracts
us to get us to come close to him. Sometimes it's revelation that gives us understanding
of God's word and sometimes it consoles and sometimes it enables us to continue the passion
of Christ. Now there's another arrow that comes from the heart of the Lord. The other
one comes from my throne. And I entrusted to the angels who are my ministers. That's
Hebrews 114, angels as the ministers of God. And they make this arrow flow over any kind
of people chastising them and exciting all to conversion. Now throughout the book of
Revelation from as soon as you get into the chastisement around chapter 6, you'll find
that it is the angels who are carrying out God's orders from heaven and they carry them
out upon the earth. Now while he was saying this, Jesus shared his pains with me, telling
me here in you also is the continuation of my redemption, that is that you suffer in
reparation for others and in substitution for them and to give glory to God. So November
24, 1903, how each word of Jesus is a link of grace. Continuing in my usual state, Louisa
said, I saw blessed Jesus in my interior for just a little. And as if he wanted to continue
removing doubts from me, he told me, daughter, I am the truth itself. That's John 14, six,
I am the way the truth and the life. And falsehood could never come from me. At the most it is
something that man does not understand. And I do this to show that if one does not understand
God's word well, how can he understand the Creator? If we don't understand God's word,
how can we understand him? However, the soul must respond by putting my word into practice.
In fact, my words are many links of grace that come out of me and are given to the soul as a gift.
Now, if she responds, she connects these links to the others, which she has already acquired. But
if she doesn't respond, she sends them back to her Creator. Now, first of all, I want to give you
the letter of James, chapter one, verses 21 and 22, where St. James tells us that we must not just
read or listen to the word, we must put it into practice. Otherwise, it will do nothing but be
our judge. The second one is Matthew 10, 13. That whatever we don't receive, it will go back to
the Lord himself. Not only this, but Jesus said, I speak only when I see that the soul has the
capacity to receive the gift. In other words, the Lord doesn't throw his pearls before swine.
And if we like the swine, are only interested in worldly things and in slop and in muddy stuff and
all the rest of it, he's not going to waste his pearls on us. So if the Lord is not communicating
his divine word to us, then it means that we're actually not open to receive it. Let me read this
again. Not only this, but I speak only when I see that the soul has the capacity to receive the
gift. And responding to me, she acquires not only many links of grace, but also many links of
divine wisdom. Now, it is extremely important for us to know that when the church tells us the seven
signs of somebody in a relationship with God, the first one is wisdom, wisdom, understanding,
counsel, fortitude, knowledge, piety, and the fear of the Lord. The first one is wisdom. If wisdom
is not growing in us, then we're not growing in relationship with God, because he is eternal
wisdom. And every touch of his adds wisdom to us. And so he continues and Jesus says, if I see all
these graces linked with response, then the soul disposes me to give her yet more gifts. So what
he's saying is the more you respond, the more you get. Now, this is what he said in the gospel to him
who has more will be given. And to him who has not even that which he has will be taken away. In other
words, if we use the gifts and the graces that God gives to us, he multiplies them. If we don't use
them, they diminish and they disappear. But if he has given us grace that we haven't used, then we
have to answer for it before him. But if I see that my gifts are sent back, I withdraw and I keep
silent. That's a very important statement. So December the 3rd, 1903, with the divine will, we are
everything without it. We are nothing. This is a VIP message. Okay, make sure you write VIP on your
page. Continuing in my usual state, my blessed Jesus came for just a little telling me, my daughter,
any human action which has no connection with the divine will puts God out of his own creation. Now,
he's telling us that whatever we do outside of the divine will is not only useless, it can be
sinful, but it's not only useless, but it keeps God out of his creation. Because God works through
his divine will, in us and in all things, even suffering itself as holy, noble and precious as it
might be before my eyes. If it is not a birth from my will, in other words, if it hasn't come from
the divine will, instead of pleasing me, it makes me indignant and is disgusting to me. Or the power
of the will of God, how holy, adorable and lovable you are. With you, we are everything, Philippians
4, 13, even if we did nothing, because your will is fertile and it gives birth to all goods for us.
Without you, we are nothing. That's literally a quotation from John 15, 5, where Jesus says,
"Without me, you can do nothing." So, without you, we are nothing even if we did everything,
because the human will is sterile and makes everything sterile. Now, here again, we come to a vital point
in our journey into divine will, and that is, if we're not putting the human will aside or not
going anywhere on this journey, we just aren't. We have to put the human will aside to let the divine
will take over. So, it really must be our motto on a daily basis, "Not my will, but thine be done,
O Lord." So, December 5, 1903, how the holy desire to receive Jesus makes up for the blessed
Eucharist, in such a way that the soul breeds God and God breeds the soul. Now, this is a very
important message about spiritual communion. It's not always possible to go to Mass, but you can
have spiritual communion. Since this morning, Louisa says, "I could not receive communion. I was
all afflicted, though resigned, and I thought to myself that if I had not been in this position of
being bedridden and of being a victim soul, I would certainly have been able to receive him."
And I said to the Lord, "You see, the state of victim soul subjects me to the sacrifice of
depriving myself of receiving you in the most holy Eucharist." Now, these writings merely says,
"The sacrament as if there was only one, hence I'm giving you the holy Eucharist." In this message,
then in other messages, Louisa refers to herself as a victim. That has a different connotation for
us today. So, you have to put in the word soul. So, you'll hear me reading this according to the
way it makes sense for us. So, she goes on, "At least accept the sacrifice of depriving myself of
you to content you as a more intense act of love for you." Here's one of the real insights into
living the spiritual life, and that is that whatever happens to you, that you can turn it into divine
currency and let it be something that will win souls for the kingdom of God, and that you can
offer it to the Lord and surrender yourself to the Lord in such a way that it becomes a wonderful
gift to him, no matter what it is, whether it's good or bad. So, Louisa said, "I can't go to communion,
but I'm offering my inability to go as a special act of love for you." Because at least, thinking
that my very privation of you proves my love for you more, sweetens the bitterness of your privation.
And as I was saying this, tears were pouring from my eyes, but oh goodness of my good Jesus, as soon as
I began to doze off, that is going to ecstasy. Without making me wait and search for a long time,
as usual immediately he came and he placed his hands on my face, he caressed me and he said,
"My daughter, poor daughter, courage, the privation of me excites the desire more." This is very
important. We say absence makes the heart grow funder. And one of the principles of the spiritual
life is that the Lord often doesn't respond immediately to us because he wants us to press on more. He
wants us to become more fervent. He wants us to make more acts of faith. He wants us to humble
ourselves more. And in the very act of depriving us of the response that we're looking for, we're
actually growing more. So, the privation of me excites the desire more and this excited the desire,
the soul breeds God. Now, the breath of God is ruach Adonai, or UACH, ADONAI. That's the Hebrew
words for the breath of God or the Holy Spirit. So, the soul breeds God. And God feeling more
ignited by this excitement of the soul breeds the soul. You and me and I in you, that's John 14,
20 to 21. So, here you're looking at the soul in union with God and the mutual love going from
one to the other in the most marvelous way. In this breathing of each other, God and the soul
thirst for love ignites more. And since love is fire, it forms the purgatory of the soul. And
this purgatory serves her not just as one communion a day as the church allows, but as a continuous
communion just as breathing is continuous. Now, notice that he says here that love is fire. The
amazing thing is that the image of love is fire. The image of God is fire, 1 John 4 7, and Hebrews 12
29, Deuteronomy 4 24, Matthew 3 11. Okay. And in Matthew 3 11, we're all to be baptized with the
Holy Spirit and fire. And when we're baptized with the Holy Spirit and fire, this fire,
purifies us, sanctifies us and glorifies us. I should have started with cleanses us, purifies us,
sanctifies us and glorifies us. And the amazing thing is that the image of hell is also fire,
but it's an inert fire. It's a fire that never cleanses, never purifies, never sanctifies,
and never glorifies. So it's a terrifying fire. But the fire of God in working in us,
the fire of the Holy Spirit and the fire of love actually makes us fit for God and does a very
important work of transformation in us. So breathing the Holy Spirit continuously then,
we're continuously growing in God. But these are all communion Jesus says of the most pure love
of the Spirit, not of the body. The body's not involved at all. And since the Spirit is more
perfect as a consequence, the love is more intense. This is how I repay not one who does not want
to receive me, but one who cannot receive me depriving himself of me to content me. So what
Jesus is saying here is that a spiritual communion is pure love and as pure love and the body is
not involved at all. Therefore there's nothing to contaminate this extraordinary communion with God.
It's absolutely fantastic. So December the 10th, 1903. Every time the soul seeks the Lord,
she receives a divine shade and a divine feature. For that I want to give you Ephesians 2, 10,
we are God's work of art created in Christ Jesus. Continuing in my usual state, Louisa says,
"I felt a weight over my soul as if the whole world weighed upon me because of the privation of
blessed Jesus." And in my immense bitterness, I did as much as I could to look for him. Then,
once he came, he told me, "My daughter, every time the soul looks for me, she receives a divine
shade, a divine feature, and is reborn in me as many times as I am reborn in her." That's absolutely
amazing. While he was saying this, she said, "I was thinking of what he had said, almost surprised
and I said, "Lord, what are you saying?" And he added, "Oh, if you knew the glory, the taste
that the whole of heaven feels in receiving this note from the earth." Now, let me read that again
because I want to change the word taste. If you knew the glory, the satisfaction is a better word
there than taste. Okay? Because that's a word that we would use. The satisfaction that the whole
of heaven feels in receiving this note from the earth, a soul that constantly seeks God all similar
to them. In other words, after they're doing all the time eternally, and all of a sudden, they see
that this is coming up from the earth as well and they're thrilled. What is the life of the
blessed? What is it that forms this life? It is that they are being reborn in God continuously
and God in them. In other words, the life is completely new all the time and renewed all the time. It
never gets old, it is eternally young. So if you're being reborn all the time, it's completely young
and completely fresh. Isn't there a saying that God is ever old and ever new? Yes, that's a very,
very ancient saying of going back beyond Christianity. Do you remember saying to Guston,
"O beauty, so ancient and so new, late have I loved thee." Okay? God is ever old and ever new.
In other words, God is there eternally and he is totally new as well. And you know that God never
patches anything. He always does something completely new. And so nor do the people in heaven ever feel
tired because they are in continuous attitude of new life in God. So let me give you some references
this paragraph. Amos 5, 6. That's Amos 5, 6. Zephaniah 2, 3. The next one is Zachariah 8, 21. Isaiah 26, 9.
And the Song of Songs, chapter 3 and verse 2. So you can see that this is something
extremely important. And if you go to John chapter 3 from verses 1 to 10, you'll have Jesus saying
to Nicodemus, "Unless you are born again, you can't even enter the kingdom of heaven."
And anyone who has been a long time on the road in spirituality knows you've got to be born and
reborn and reborn and reborn and reborn. And apparently that's the way in heaven as well as
we've just read. So December 17, 1903. The adoration that the most holy virgin did when she encountered
Jesus carrying the cross. And this is the true spirit of adoration. So this is a very important
message then on adoration. Put a VIP on it, okay? I like putting VIP on some of the messages
just to highlight the fact that you should take really deep note of it. So continuing in my usual
state, Louisa says, "For a few instances I saw blessed Jesus with the cross on his shoulders,
in the act of encountering his most holy mother that is on the way of the cross."
And I said to him, "Lord, what did your mother do in this most sorrowful encounter?" Very good question.
And he answered, "My daughter, she did nothing but a most profound and simple act of adoration.
And since the simpler the act, the more easily it unites to God, most simple spirit.
In this act she infused herself in me and continued what I myself was doing in my interior."
Now this is what the Lord has taught us through Louisa that we must do, look at Jesus, do what
he does. And we do it in our interior, we do it on a spiritual level, we join ourselves to him,
we imitate, we echo, we give him back, we enter into his acts, we take them upon ourselves in the
divine will and we offered them to the Father for exactly the same reasons that Jesus is offering
them. So we're actually participating in the Passion of Jesus as core redeemers. It's a very
wonderful gift that's given to us. And Jesus said, "This was immensely pleasing to me, more than if
she had done any greater thing." In fact, the true spirit of adoration consists in this,
that the soul dissolves herself and finds herself in the divine sphere.
Now that adoration is extremely important, many people do hours of adoration and they make the
mistake of reading all the time or saying prayers and they don't allow themselves to really sink
into the presence of God so that our spirit is one with his. So here it is again, the true
spirit of adoration consists in this. The creature dissolves herself and finds herself in the divine
sphere. She adores all that God does and she unites with him. Do you think that when the mouth
adores but the mind is somewhere else, that is true adoration? That is the mind adores but the
will is far away from me. That's number two. Or one power adores me and the others are all
disordered. In other words, it's not really the whole of us that's in the adoration. No, I want
everything for myself that's Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10, God's right to exclusive love.
No, I want everything for myself and everything I have given her in me. This is the greatest act
of religion, of adoration that the creature can do for me. Now we need to read that over and over
and over again until it sinks in. It's extremely important and we have Blessed Mother as our model
to do this. December the 21st, 1903. The effects of the sorrows of the Blessed Mother,
that is her seven sorrows and the glory that she enjoys in heaven. This morning I found myself
outside of myself, Luisa says, and looking into the vault of the heavens I saw seven most refulgent
suns. These are representing the seven sorrows of Blessed Mother. But their shape was different
from the sun that we see in the sky. It started with the shape of a cross and it ended with a point
and this point was inside a heart. At first it could not be seen clearly
because the light of these suns was so great as to not allow one to see who was inside.
But the nearer I drew the more clearly it appeared that our queen mother was inside.
In my interior I kept saying how I would like to ask her whether she wants me to try to go out
of this state without waiting for the priest. Now instead of following the vision that she's
seeing, Luisa has this distraction to ask her something completely practical. She has been told
many times that it really is God's will for her, but this is the thorn in her side that she finds
very difficult to put up with. In the meantime I found myself near her and I told her and she
answered with the kurt no. It's not God's will if you do go out of that state. Why do you get the
kurt no? She should have been following what the Lord was showing her. And so she said,
Luisa said I was left mortified by this answer and the most holy virgin turned to a multitude of
people who surrounded her and said to them, listen to what she wants to do. Luisa doesn't appear to
realize at this particular point that if she doesn't do the intercession and suffering of a
victim's soul that the world will self-destruct, she doesn't seem to grasp it at this point.
And everyone said no no don't let her do it. Then drawing near me all goodness she told me my daughter
courage along the way of sorrow. See these seven suns which came out from within my heart are my
seven sorrows which produced much glory and splendor for me. These suns the fruits of my sorrows
dart continuously through the throne of the most blessed Trinity which feeling touched the
word on the book is wounded sends me seven channels of grace continually making me their owner and
I dispense them for the glory of all heaven for the relief of the purging souls and for the benefit
of the pilgrim souls. Look what we would lose if she hadn't accepted these seven sorrows and look
what the world would lose if Luisa goes out of this state but Luisa has to wake up and just realize
how important is the task that God has given to her. So then she disappeared. So December the 22nd
1903 is another very very important message. The cross forms the incarnation of Jesus in the womb
of souls and the incarnation of the soul in God. Now this is an extremely important message. It
needs to be read over and over and over again to take it on board. As I was in my usual state
Luisa said my adorable Jesus came as crucified and after he shared his pains with me while I was
suffering he told me my daughter in the creation I gave my image to the soul that's Genesis 1
27 and Genesis 2 7. So Genesis 1 27 and Genesis 2 7. I gave my image to the soul. In the incarnation
I gave my divinity, divinizing humanity and since in the very act, in the very instant in which the
divinity incarnated itself in humanity it incarnated itself in the cross. Now one of the things that
the Catholic Church is actually famous for on earth is its understanding and teaching of the cross.
Many other denominations of Christians won't handle the cross they want to push it aside.
It incarnated itself in the cross in such a way that from the moment I was conceived I was conceived
united with the cross. It can be said that just as my cross was united with me in the incarnation
which I did in the womb of my mother so does my cross watch this now form as many other incarnations
of mine in the wombs of souls. And just as the cross forms my incarnation in souls the cross
is the incarnation of the soul in God. Can you avoid the cross? Absolutely no. Therefore look
up Matthew 16 in which Peter is called to be the the chief stone that the Lord will build the
church on and immediately he rejects the cross and immediately Jesus says get behind me Satan
and then immediately after that he says everybody everybody everybody must have the cross otherwise
they're not a Christian. So there's an old saying which says that a Christian without a cross is an
anachronism contradiction in terms. This is why the cross doesn't leave you it's it's extremely
important. So just as the cross forms my incarnation in souls the cross is the incarnation of the soul
in God. Destroying in her everything that gives of human nature you'd have to add the word human
and filling her with the divinity so much as to form a sort of incarnation. So we become little
incarnations in inverted commas okay. God in the soul and the soul in God so that's your John 14
20 to 21 you and me and I and you both completely won.
I remain as though enchanted on hearing that the cross is the incarnation of the soul in God
and Jesus repeated I'm not saying union I'm saying incarnation that means that he genuinely
lives his life in us and lives his life through us and speaks through us and breeds through us
and sees through us and hears through us. Very important I'm not saying union he said I'm saying
incarnation because the cross penetrates so much into our human nature as to make this nature of
ours become suffering and where there is suffering there is God as God and suffering cannot be a part
isn't that absolutely incredible because the only thing that God didn't have in heaven human
beings gave him which was suffering and sorrow and because of that because we gave God the gift
of suffering and sorrow God gives us the gift of suffering and sorrow in order to purify
and sanctify and make us ready for heaven and without the friends of suffering and sorrow we're
not going anywhere and the cross forming this incarnation renders this union more stable
and the separation of God from the soul almost as difficult as separating suffering from nature
so if the cross is there and the suffering is there and we are loving God in and through it all
he is not going anywhere and you see from the early volumes of Louisa's work that whenever
Louisa is suffering very deeply the crucifixion that Jesus never leaves her he's there all the time
all the time and it was a totally unique experience that she had other saints didn't have that
so the cross forming this incarnation renders this union between God and the soul more stable
and the separation of God and the soul becomes almost as difficult as separating suffering
from human nature on the other hand through union the separation can occur easily because if you
unite two things you can separate them it's understood always that this is not the incarnation
but a simile of the incarnation hence i say a small incarnation in inverted commas okay
so the next paragraph deals with divine will work filling in the voids around God's throne
so you need to put that in as a heading there filling the voids around God's throne and it's a
very very important message quite apart from what we've just read this is a completely new message
and very important in itself so having said this he disappeared but after a little while
he came back in the act of his passion when he was covered with a pro-brium with ignominies
and with spit and i said to him lord teach me what i could do to move this a pro-brium away from you
and to give you back honors and praises and adorations now that is a vip question if you ask
the right question you're going to get the right answer if you don't ask the question you'll be left
in your ignorance so she has asked a very important question and jesus said to her my daughter
around my throne there is a void and this void must be filled with the glory that creation owes me
because he is the author of creation and we at least owe him thanksgiving and praise for what he has
done so one who sees me despised by the other human creatures and honors me not only for herself
but for others makes honors for me arise again in this void now for that i want to give you one
samuel 230 one samuel 230 it says he who honors me i will honor when the soul sees me this is number
two when the soul sees me unloved and loves me she makes love for me arise again when she sees
that i fill creatures with benefits while they are not grateful to me and do not even thank me and
she is grateful to me also if those benefits were given to her and she thanks me she makes the flower
of gratitude and thanksgiving rise again okay so there's the honor the love the thanksgiving that
we give to him and so with all the rest that creation owes me but denies to me in awful in gratitude
now human beings are identified in the 36 volumes as completely ungrateful for what God has done
for them now since all this is an overflow of the charity of the soul who gives me not only what
she herself owes me and what overflows from herself but she does it for others we do it for everybody
past present and future since this glory and these flowers that she sends to me into this void
around my throne are full of charity that means divine love they receive a more beautiful shade
which is pleasing to me so i want to give you one Corinthians 13 13 and the greatest of these is love
and one Corinthians 14 one you must want love more than anything else
so that's extremely important and you need to read that over and over about giving God glory and
praise and thanksgiving and worship and everything else to fill the voids for the whole human race
and do it in his divine will of course so december the 24th 1903 desire makes Jesus born in the soul
and the same for the devil so this morning i was in my usual state Louisa says and baby Jesus
came and on seeing him so very little for as if he had just been born i said to him my pretty little
one what was the cause who made you come from heaven to be born so little in the world now again
a very important question which Jesus answers at different times because he could have come as an
adult why did he come as an infant and he said the reason was love i want to give you one john
four seven god is love i want to give you sam one four five verse seventeen god only ever acts
out of love and i want to give you john fifteen nine as the father has loved me jesus said that
is he loves me infinitely absolutely eternally unconditionally so i love you
the reason was love not only this but my birth in time was the outpouring of love of the most
holy trinity towards human creatures in an outpouring of love of my mother i was born from her womb
and in an outpouring of love i am reborn in souls now notice that birth is supposed to
take place in love everything is meant to be love we were meant to be conceived in love to be
nurtured in love to be born in love to grow up in love and when we become adult to commit ourselves
to love and to give love and life to others but this outpouring is formed by desire
as soon as the soul begins to desire me i am conceived the more she advances in her desire
the more i keep growing in the soul and when this desire fills her whole interior and reaches the
point of overflowing outside then i am reborn in the whole of man in his mind his mouth his works
and his steps okay now st john of the cross has written whole books on this subject like the
ascent of my karma that everything begins with the desire uh let me give you a complete an example
that's outside of the spiritual life i will never become a pilot flying an airplane if i don't want
to be a pilot if i don't have the desire to be a pilot i will not go through the training i will
not go through the trouble i will not do anything about it it all starts with the desire if i want
to be a nurse i have to want to be a nurse if i want if if i am to become a teacher i have to want
it if i am to become anybody else i have to want it everything begins with desire and the people
who succeed whether it's earthly things or heavenly things they succeed when the desire grows and grows
and grows and you action it more and more as i say john of the cross has written a book on that
now now we look at the other side of the coin jesus says it's all in the opposite way the devil
also makes his births and souls as soon as the soul begins to desire and to want evil the devil is
conceived with his perverted works and if this desire is nourished the devil grows and fills all
up man's interior with passions the most ugly and disgusting ones as john 844 everyone who sins
is a slave and reaches the point of overflowing outside as man lets all devices rush in
my daughter how many births the devil makes in these most sad times in other words people are
going after sin and they just don't realize that they are giving birth to evil
my daughter how many births the devil has in these sad times if men and demons had the power to do
it they would have destroyed my births in souls that is the extraordinary thing that when people go
towards evil and wickedness they don't just keep it for themselves they want to destroy others and
you see that in the way adults attack and destroy children and if they themselves have lost all
chastity and purity they want to take it away from the child as well it's frightening so
december the 28th 1903 how all lives are in christ i want to give you one carinthians 12
verses 12 to 30 that's the body of christ we're all in the body of christ
after i struggled very much louisa says my blessed jesus came for just a little
and made me see that many human souls inside yeah made me see many human souls inside of his humanity
so the body of christ is that each one of us are cells in the body of christ
he said to me my daughter all human lives are in my humanity in heaven as though inside a cloister
hence the church teaches that everything is through him with him and in him
and since they are inside my cloister the regime or government or rule of their lives
comes from me so if something is inside of my body i'm in charge if i'm inside of the body of christ
he's in charge not only this but my humanity being the cloister conducts the lives of each soul
in other words he is lord and master and in preparation for the revelation of the divine will
the lord has taught this to people through the charismatic renewal for example
what joy is mine when souls remain in this cloister and the echo that comes from my humanity
blends with the echo of each human life on the earth and what bitterness is mine when i see
that souls are not content and they go out of it others remain but forced and unwilling
they do not submit to the rules and to the government of my cloister therefore my echo does
not blend with theirs so here you have first of all the fact that we are in this cloister of the lord
and then we have the sadness that we may not actually stay there because we have free will or
we might stay there just grudgingly therefore not adding to the glory of god at all so i want to
leave that there for a moment